this is a production of cornell
university
thank you everyone for
coming and for listening
uh like he said
i'm going to be talking about genetic
loading saba
finding deleterious mutations and
looking at what they do um
and so
as many of you may know
south is a clonely propagating crop
through it's probably through stem
cuttings
and uh if you
also know if you've read or watched a
science fiction
uh novel or film uh cloning has some
costs and uh one of those is in uh
the
evolutionary principle oh
sorry this is not moving
there we go
uh a molar's ratchet moles ratchet
states that if you don't have sexual
recombination
you're going to have an accumulation of
deleterious mutations
and here in this
scene kind of a pictorial way uh under
sexual reproduction even disregarding
anything like recombination
um you can purge these deleterious
mutations here those red symbols
um
just through uh independent assortment
but under clonal reproduction
um
the delta is mutation especially if it's
recessive
is is masked and never
never exposed as a homozygote so its
effects linger and uh that's the genetic
load um
and so one of the things we want to ask
is well if we expect a lot of this
genetic load and it's propagated crop
um
how do we find it
and so one of the ways
we can detect the llc mutations is
through evolutionary conservation and
comparing genomics
well the hypothesis being here that over
millions of years we expect that natural
selection will have purged out that
tree's mutations
and that
if we look across species then we should
be able to see which sites are conserved
sorry
this is a red
i guess
[Music]
okay can you hear me
all right
where was that okay so um
so if we take uh just this example
sequencing cassava
and
uh right now we know nothing about it
it's assuming everything's neutral but
if we start aligning some
species some distant diverged species
we can start to get a sense of maybe the
conservation state of some of these
bases
and as we get more and more species we
can even start to say well well this
this red side is conserved everywhere
but we haven't derived the casaba so
we're going to predict that this is
probably deleterious and maybe there's
some semi-conserved other sites out
there we can't say as much about but uh
and then some purely neutral sites
and so um
[Music]
one of the things also to highlight is
that uh using
these inter-specific comparisons allows
us to eliminate the effects of linkage
or drift that we'd have by looking at
stuff like allele frequencies
uh within a single species
um also maybe the question comes up well
why don't you still align every species
that exists and see what happens if
you're trying to you know use evolution
well the problem is if we align
arabinopsis and maze and all that to
this
nothing's going to align it's going to
be very gappy it's a little too diverged
and so what we want to do is maximize
our evolutionary sampling while
maintaining you know a comparative
biology and similar alignable space
so we did this by um sampling around 30
genomes across public repositories and
botanic gardens
we
assembled these um sequence them using
short and long read technologies
and assemble them um and i've kind of
glazed over that but that was a lot of
work on the project but
we come out of this with uh with a big
set of
assembled genomes
highlighted in red is cassava
but
you know there's some closer and farther
related to cassava but kind of the
reiterate here is we're trying to sample
as much as we can within a similar
evolutionary background so you get both
a broad more alignment space and deeper
evaluation at every base pair
um and so you know what
what do we do once we have this
is we use a tool called genome
evolutionary profiling or gerp
and uh what gurp is it's
very simply it's a
method of
evaluating evolutionary constraint it
produces something called a projected
substitution score basically if you it
assumes or it
estimates the amount of neutral mutation
that would happen in a region and then
looks at a site and say well how many
mutations should have occurred and if
they didn't occur that's a rejected
substitution
and uh that's indicates conservation
so we take a multiple sequence alignment
put it through the group
pipeline
and come out with this
big set of curved scores across and the
benefit here is this
as we put all these pieces in here we're
going to evaluate a lot more sites and a
lot greater depth meaning we get a more
rejected substitution kind of
differentiation so what we're really
interested in is these these most highly
conserved sites
and we expect mutations of these sites
to be deleterious
and then um you know
the question is if we expect these are
you know effective positive functional
elements of the genome
how can we use those in something like
genomic prediction
to improve our estimates or use that
functional information
and
but i do have to state some assumptions
first using genomic prediction
especially if i'm talking about the g
block kind of standard method
uh if the markers are tightly linked to
positive loci
uh then adding positive steps is
unlikely to benefit operation
so
but that uh isn't always the case and we
would assume that it might be beneficial
if we include this functional
information in in situations where
uh the ld structure is broken down but
things aren't as tightly linked and two
of those informations might be in a
rapid cycling with current selection or
in a diverse or cross-population
prediction
and so the method we're going to use
here is called a multi-kernel block
basically simply put this allows us to
separate our estimated effects from the
two different sets of markers our
genome-wide snips and then
our accusative deleteriousness
and the assumption going in here is that
these these are coming from
a different varying effects so these
kind of this
assumed distributions uh is just kind of
an example of what we think
might be going on
and so now we've tested uh in a
cross-population patient model
using uh we found around 10 000 uh
segregating sites using our conserved
curb sites
and we tested this in two separate
breeding programs in east and west
africa
and so we used
information from iita the breeding
program in nigeria to both do within and
cross population tradition to uh another
great part of uganda at nike
um
and here's just the first results which
i'll point to you basically
adding the deleterious here all these 10
000 snips
didn't change any predictions you see um
but we do see the predicted drop from
going from within to cross population
um and the the different germplasm
uh well there's a lot of explanations
that i'll get to throughout the
presentation but one of the big ones
here is that
these 10 000 markers is just too large a
set and it's likely just tracking the
same variation as the genome one set
would
and so it's not really uh
uh
we really need to know is well what
information how how much information
will we need
uh what grade
could we get some benefit and that led
us to look at some simulations uh to
what when would this be beneficial
and so this uh simulation framework i
basically just took the real genotypes
from these populations looked at those
conserved you know deleterious sites
and then simulated marker effects at
those sites um i used a few different uh
genetic architectures basically just
assuming different orders of magnitude
qtl
um
then from that i see the phenotypes and
hell you know looked uh kept track of
what the highest uh effect variance
would be these heist effect qtl and
perform a general prediction so the
baseline is going to be using just the
whole snips
then i'm going to use all of the
positive stamps for these deleterious
numbers then we'll look at just paring
down to the highest effect what what
happens
so here's the results uh these are just
the cross population let me walk along
the x-axis for you
so here is when we don't add anything
but the genome line snips
and um
then as we move
all of them and then as we go down to
just the uh the top
series snips and the different colors
are those genetic architectures and
right now we're just looking at the
cross population results
um what we do see is this blue line
shows that uh you know under a highly
polygenic trait
even knowing that the most cause of qtl
the highest effect is is not going to
help anything but that's thousands of
qtl very small and i don't expect that
to be true
but we do see a big bump or in the uh
other genetic architectures but only
after we kind of narrowed in on the on
the top snips the other grain in red
after only including the top 100 top 10
including everything does not help us
so um i then you know i look at the
within population as well and i expected
this to
be different from the cross
uh but it looks very similar so maybe
my ld patterns aren't as quite as
different as i thought they might be or
you know this is just one iteration of
the simulation of trying to perform more
to get a better grade of what this
should look like
so that kind of leads us to say well ten
thousand once again it's just too big a
set and how can we get a better grade
scale of what's the highest impact so
some recent work from a former lab
member guillaume ramstein suggests that
by incorporating protein information uh
we can improve the weighting of these
variants as a variant of the conserved
sites and we saw significant
improvements by using doing this
weighting and doing a prediction with
those five effect markers
i'm going to not going to go too into
the business but using some uh
information from databases like sift and
uterus that track evolution and protein
evolution and protein folding
uh you get a random forest model that
predicts conservation
uh with a few other uh covariance but
this gives us these conservation weights
which is what i'm trying to get at is a
more graded scale of what's the highest
impact um i'm going to just show this
this is my compare of my observed
conservation versus predicted and the
only thing to highlight here is that um
there's an enrichment for rare alleles
in this predicted versus the observed
meaning maybe we're capturing more
rarely those are supposed to be
deleterious as well so
um you know we're hopefully getting more
signal there
and um as fortunately when i go to my
real predictions including these weights
uh has not yet given the desired
boost and accuracy like i've seen the
simulation
and there's very many possible
explanations um
it could be that maybe yield looks like
that blue line maybe it is really highly
polygenic i still don't believe that oh
but
you know it could be maybe the
deleterious estimates i still need to
work on getting a pipeline down and
tweaking
it could be that root yields uh in a
clover crop it's not the same as grain
yield in an outcrossing crop and it may
not be related to as much to fitness as
as that might be
um
and orgy or it could be an ld still
there or there's just g by e could be
this
and so you know there's there's a couple
possible problems but there's a lot of
avenues are still going through so it's
not like i'm discouraged quite yet
um
and you know to include you know we've
assembled these genomes and we have deep
assessment conservation across a huge
portion of the cassava genome
including these functional information i
think it has the potential to improve
genetic prediction but there's some
caveats and under only under certain
circumstances but the really important
is that we need to get at what are the
highest effect variants
um and you know
we see some difficulties but i think
there's a lot of a lot of room to
improve and
we're getting there
and i'd like last like to thank uh lab
members especially from robin's lab
kelly chris and francisco for their
support and for the buccal lab and
center sarah kim amy and tweed and i
also thank my funding
and the national cassava community for
all the work they do and i will take any
questions
from
martin
did you consider directional dominance
model allowing a non-zero mean for
deleterious kernel effects distribution
might be appropriate here i do have a
dominance model i've not looked at
directional dominance
so
let's talk let's uh
um
[Music]
uh joey lee
do you think it would be helpful to
include genomes outside of the 4bc
family to cut down 10 000 steps to find
more concern to improve your prediction
yeah i think i think it does have the
potential there are other
publicly available genomes out there
that are closer than arabidopsis but uh
but still uh you know that could have
improved the depth
um
it's still hard because
it's it's hard to get a real graded
score and a curve it's really just this
is really conserved or it's not um even
though there's a variation in the scores
but
it has a lot more to do with
how much how many
species get aligned at any given site
thank you again there's any questions
i probably went over time
[Music]
well let's thank kevin
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu